you
sorry about that
hello everybody that actually startled
me when I loaded this up um I I loaded
up once I was like oh I have to get
downtown camera I have to do that so
sorry guys I just had to I couldn't
resist so this is called Nyctophobia
which I'm assuming is a fear of getting
nicked while shaving or people named
Nick or old Saint Nick which I am very
scared of so let's get into it no I
don't want log in a game joltin go away
not that I don't appreciate games old
they have many many many many many many
come on yes I'm sure
oh yes yes you have a job okay
that job is to be a security guard
during the night shift that job at a
local office complex mm-hmm you and
Marley to it every night my decent paper
- enough to keep it going anyway tonight
Marley's just called off sick so you got
to do the shift
alone should be bad right hmm well the
powers just gone off and I don't think
you're alone anymore
nope not afraid of the dark it's a
little dark in here what happened to the
lights
oh they went off power must have gone
out Oh stock to the backup supply on
okay should be switches on the floor
that turns it on I should probably look
for them who are you talking to buddy is
that a heart not a good thing
oh there's my heart oh I see whew
aha hi what what's a buzzin somebody aah
what hell was that I ain't see anything
what did you see I didn't say anything
what was that oh is that Jesus I didn't
see anything I just heard a loud noise
that's any interesting mechanic I like
that heart being there sorry if this is
hard for you guys to see I mean it's
very small in the game window but this
is actually really cool I gotta admit
this is pretty creative as far as a
horror game goes I mean I haven't played
many I'm play many top-down shooters of
any type um I like that it's kind of
ambient noise right ahem what was that
Ike the torch startled us things maybe I
should turn it off
any of them what do you mean when near
them how do I know when I'm near them
what things
oh that's what the buzzing is okay so I
need to let myself calm down good being
in the total darkness ah yo yo don't
care I'm running away what do I care if
I start all the things some down here I
don't even know what these things is I
don't know there's something here oh
okay go in this door room I'm looking
for some sort of light the whole room is
getting a little wonky huh
okay what see things yeah nothing I'm
not so you need to start explaining what
you're seeing so I can get out of here
huh is one you should get the power
started I think five more should do it
five more Jebus what is it how do I use
it how do I use it how do I hear how do
I you dead how I'm trying to press some
buttons here don't seem to be clicking
on it I thought it was a floor panel
thing that I step on but I can't step on
it okay wait maybe I already used it and
now I need to just move on
this is just a little wonky like it's
hard to see I can't even see if or when
there is something actually
near me mmm either way I like this this
is a very very creative game I love it
what why Mike what well I've slowed down
quite a lot my god
hmm holy balls you guys are stomach you
didn't tell me what the hell's going on
calm down okay take deep breaths bro
your heart's gonna explode can I calm
down for a second or am I just
permanently in panic mode like a
permanently in panic mode now my heart
can't take my heart can t take a much
more of this okay there we go okay
starting to be a little more shut up the
shop
I guess Marley didn't call in sick he
got Mert alized by monsters I do not
like this game I changed my opinion from
my previous an a a Circassian this game
sucks this game is awful what I saw
something W is coming at me tell me why
come here me ah oh that was the floor
panel good touch it
use that how do you use that there it is
take it do something with it what is in
the darkness what lurks beyond the
shadow the veil of shadows I lied my
soul
my god oh how do I get out of here
what do I keep turning up my life ah man
this needs to calm the hell down I kind
of take your dis ah can't handle it man
it's giving me a headache just because
the level is moving so much I think's
supposed to give you this feeling of
disorientation - my flashlight is now
failing me
my torch as the Brits would say and as
this game apparently says ok calm down
just calm down bro
ah calm down I'm not going down my light
is gone I'm boned boom-boom bud
my buddy hahaha
where am I going I don't even know
anymore
oh stop clearing your throat man okay
I'm I'm totally lost
I can't see anything cuz my torch is now
gone it's so gone for some reason I'm
having trouble going down this hallway
what is down here what happened
we were said coming down light tired up
by the Dom bun turn make something
happen I don't know I don't know I think
panicking is not helping get out of the
building man it's not worth it I don't
even know how to turn on the lights I do
what fast why the heart is not about to
go that fast
that is the logically fast heartbeat
it's gonna explode I better explain what
what what what happened what what
happened seriously what happened
did the game just reset itself did I die
what happened
what happened I want to know yeah kill
me don't kill me kill me huh laughs what
is it what is it I want to see it
show it to me okay
aah like they can't I don't know hi OOP
okay I'm actually turning them on this
time I got to I got to I wanna play it
anymore okay I got poo I'm trying to
keep in the same general areas and
remember where I've been
poppet okay
ah this is the slow-motion hallway hello
hello evil creatures who look at us no
you go in there you [ __ ] you suck it up
okay this should be three more now what
do you mean I just did three all right
whatever you suck it up [ __ ] and you
keep moving forward you a-hole
apparently they don't want to nibble on
your giblets so just keep moving forward
I will stab something in the place you
don't want a stabbed
keep your light on scaring him is good
thing I think I don't know I don't know
just keep moving forward
come on I've gotten three there's no
more aha wait wait okay what's in here
I'm trying to build a map in my head
it's not working out too well me no it's
not okay moving I'd be a great
motivational speaker you figure out game
over and fern you scared little baby
oh just baby one is bottle even though
I'm screaming louder than am me no I
won't keep going it won't kill you aha
that's four just need two more
apparently oh god it's so bad I can't
even I can't even see where I'm going
now oh boy I'm not gonna make it I'm not
gonna make it I'm not gonna make it
oh I got a leg up I think there's one
more hey I don't even think there are
anything in the dark I think this guy is
just like afraid of the dark and he's
just making stuff up with his mind okay
come on I gotta be getting close shut up
push aha one more to go one more to go
come on you can do it before your heart
explodes
come on move man move okay turn off your
light just a Oh save some of your
flashlights I think I know where I'm
going maybe
kind of a little bit yeah turn on the
light
calm down calm down calm down calm down
calm down
whoo calm down calm the F down man
you've got one more just one more
and then you're out of here you're
scot-free you can go home to your loving
wife who is definitely not cheating on
you with a mailman oh what's this
I pass I've been everywhere mmm piss off
piss off pissed
aah path path I don't know where else to
go
oh I'm so boned again I'm boned a leg
again I don't know where the last one is
I don't know where the last one is calm
down just stand and calm down oh [ __ ]
why are you picking back up okay
whatever this guy is uncontrollable
I don't know how to make him calm the F
down let's go oh what's over here what's
over here something-something
Table nine all right God
fudge wick this is just to another
hallway come on man you're so close I
can smell taste it
I can smashed uh what's a deer ah no
give an audience of us don't die don't
die yourself us where is it huh that's
the last one I put ahead to the elevator
no you son of a [ __ ]
God not the escape mechanic that's pool
that's ball I can't see anything my part
I'm dying ah shut up where's the exit I
came through here gah I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead my heart's gonna explode the
whole world has gone topsy-turvy come on
I need some light I'm not gonna make aah
aah
oh [ __ ] I'm so close god damn it okay oh
okay I didn't make it dammit okay all
right you guys try it for yourself see
if you can make it I might pick this up
again see if I can actually do it next
time but anyway I'm all the time so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
ah
Oh
yeah